what do you think about this Matt Brown
thinks that if there was an MMA fight
between Jake Paul and Nate Diaz Jake
would still win let me take this in for
a second you have the immortal taking
Jake Paul's side he says he would
probably win yeah we already know he can
outbox him right when was the last time
you seen Nate Diaz take someone down I
don't think he'll be able to take him
down even if he tries to like he's way
way under sized Jake Paul's so much
bigger than him I don't know what weight
it'll be at probably 18 185 Nate's not a
great wrestler it's going to end up
staying on the feet what difference
would it be like if it stays on the feet
I agree with the immortal here Jake's
power with 4 o gloves on and some of the
Jitsu trips could get Jake in some
trouble and if that fight goes to the
ground it's over so fast but I would put
Jake at a minus 105 the distance is
different in MMA so Jake would have to
adjust to that could even go Nate minus
105 just because his experience in the
Octagon the distance if it goes to the
ground this thing's over